elle vous êtes une des figures du
mouvement des gilets jaunes peut-être
une première réaction parce que
manifestement les policiers qu'on voit
sur les vidéos été identifiés oui ils
ont été identifiés mais comme à
plusieurs reprises ou l'igpn a pu
identifier des policiers et les écarter
pour états ou des tas de raisons alors
on se pose des questions les raisons
après qui font qu'ils sont oubliés en
macule passion pas ou si ça donne des
suites aux affaires ou aux plaintes
déposées par les victimes
donc voilà là en l'occurrence à apporter
apparemment ça n'a pas été facile pour
qu'ils puissent les identifier surtout
qu'il y est on va dire une assistance un
des dés de la hiérarchie police mais le
vrai problème c'est que il ya énormément
de plaintes qui ont été déposées depuis
nos événements et on peut se rendre
compte que bon là on est sur l'acte iii
imaginez vous tous les actes qu'il ya eu
depuis plus d'un an et demi avec
énormément de plaintes qui sont
retournés sans suite classée sans suite
ont des raisons qu'on n'arrive pas à
définir réellement et surtout pour une
absence d'identification de certains crs
ou policiers par rapport à l'or et rio
donc voilà alors justement cette
identification va peut-être faire
pouvoir avancer les choses dans cette
salle on l'espère mais il est certain
que par rapport au nombre de plaintes
qui ont été classés il y en a plus de
350 qui ont été classées sans suite
puis puis toutes celles qui sont encore
en attente il ya à peu près 380 plaintes
qui sont en attente de pouvoir aboutir
franchement moi je trouve pas qu'il ya
une bonne volonté de vouloir apporter
réparation aux personnes qui ont été
victimes dans 1 ou un abus de pouvoir ou
une violence policière j'estime qu'à un
moment donné il faudrait enfin on a le
sentiment et il faudrait pas qu'on
laisse penser que
les policiers sont au dessus des lois
parce qu'ils sont bien là pour nous dans
un premier temps pays sont là pour faire
respecter cette loi
je suis désolé mais quand n'importe quel
citoyen qui n'est pas habilité ou qui
fait pas partie d'une administration ou
qui n'est pas un élu ou un haut
fonctionnaire commet une infraction ou
doit répondre de la justice je peux vous
dire que c'est bien plus rapide même si
on sait la longueur de la justice et le
temps du d'effectuer une enquête
il ya en même temps la volonté de
laisser penser aussi peut-être pour
l'opinion publique que la justice il ya
deux poids deux mesures et qu'il serait
intéressant de montrer qu'il n'y a pas
une impunité
chez les policiers et c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il ya eu toutes ces affaires
parce que si dès le début il y avait eu
un arrêt de deux ce qui représente
l'état le ministre de l'intérieur où les
prêts très où le président lui-même
plutôt faire un déni de réalité de
violences policières oud ou d'abus
d'autorité et ben peut-être que les
choses elle n'aurait pas déborder autant
de fois et surtout depuis aussi
longtemps parce que ça aurait peut-être
freiné un peu cette répression un peu en
laisser aller qui a des conséquences sur
les personnes sur des simples citoyens
alors certains police etc ont été mis en
examen disent avoir écouté les ordres
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il manque
peut-être certaines personnes sur le
banc des accusés lorsque nous on a porté
plainte ne serait ce que pour la journée
du 16 novembre pour l'anniversaire des
gilets jaunes on a porté plainte
la plainte a été déposée au nom de
didier lallement donc tuer le préfet
mais x aussi parce que on est contraint
et forcé de constater avec les
discussions qu'on a pu avoir les polices
avec les policiers les crs et les
gendarmes ils sont des exécutants et que
bien malheureusement bien souvent ils
acquiescent lorsque ils ont des ordres
au risque d'être eux-mêmes sanctionner
ou être mis à l'écart
donc à un moment donné le droit de
réserve a des limites lorsqu'on sait que
on défend une corporation la représente
on doit la représenter du mieux que
possible n'est pas autour de soi laisser
aller à toute exaction ou
toute injustice donc on a pu voir des
personnes qui ont été matraquées qui ont
été blessées et laisser comme ça en
toute impunité moi je me rappelle aussi
de de ce qu'a subi
mélanie qui habite amiens qui étaient
venus sur l'acte 2 d'ici vivent le long
de kate gema qui suite à une charge des
policiers qui arrivait derrière elle a
été matraqué à trois ou quatre reprises
au niveau de la nuque et au niveau de la
tête qui est tombé en perdant
connaissance qui a porté plainte auprès
de l'igpn
malgré qu'ils ont identifié le policier
qui a commis cette action donc c'est
fait a été du coup classée sans suite
alors que la perse le policier est
identifié la victime est bien présente à
la porté plainte à la fois obtenir
réparation donc à un moment donné voilà
les raisons pour lesquelles on demande
une indépendance de la commission
denquête donc de l'igpn
on demande qu'elle soit impartial et
qu'elles soient pas uniquement composée
que de policiers
il pourrait y avoir des avocats il
pourrait y avoir des médecins il
pourrait y avoir des psychologues il
pourrait y avoir des personnes ou des
personnes qui ont des connaissances à
pour être aussi il pourrait aussi avoir
quelques policiers mais pas que vous
comprenez pour cette impartialité pour
essayer de 2,2 de faire que les gens
puissent obtenir réparation de la
blessure est d aider des causes à effets
que leurs blessures a occasionné par ce
que leur vie derrière elle est chamboulé
allait bouleverser pour certains ils
sont handicapés seront handicaper
lourdement et avis donc voilà il est
temps vraiment de montrer beaucoup plus
que le gouvernement est
le l'ensemble des organismes existants
il montre vraiment qu'il n'y a pas
d'impunité pour la police et que
normalement ils sont là pour nous et ils
sont pas complice des exactions ou des
blessures qu'il a pu y avoir parce que
du coup il ya une telle défiance des
politiques
une telle défiance des organismes d'état
justement et voilà on les confond le
pointe du doigt c'est pour ça que mardi
pour la en date du 14 juillet date de la
révolution on prend pas la bastille on
sera devant l'igpn pendant deux heures
et on va redonner la parole à tous ceux
qui ont porté plainte ou les blessés
toutes les victimes qui souhaiteront le
faire pour se rappeler que du coup pas
d'être blessé c'est pas rien ça a des
conséquences et notre société elle doit
prendre en charge les plus faibles et
les gens qui tirait cam justice est qui
et qui ont besoin d'être dédommagés et
pris en charge pendant ses blessures
parce que bout de gilet jaune
aujourd'hui j'ai pu voir beaucoup de
familles qui ont perdu des proches et
qui ont porté plainte sont laissés comme
ça dans le dans l'oubli dans la bande
ont livré les menus sans pouvoir s'en
sortir voilà tout simplement monsieur
lellouche merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous rappelle que vous êtes à l'une
des figures du mouvement d'études et
jaune merci